So the classic approach to negotiation is
positional bargaining.
In positional bargaining I have a position,
you have a position, and we each haggle over
those positions.
Now the rules to positional bargaining are
very clear: You start with an extreme demand
but not so extreme that the other side thinks
that you’re crazy or bluffing.
You can concede stubbornly, and you demonstrate
a greater willingness in the other side to
walk away from the negotiation table.
So you go to the car dealer.
You want to buy a Corvette.
The car salesperson says, “$80,000 take
it or leave it.”
You say “80?
I’ll tell you what: 40, take it or leave
it.”
And you start arguing and haggling, crossing
your arms.
Threatening to leave.
An hour later the car salesperson brings that
number down to 70.
You’ve gone up to 50.
You each then demonstrate a greater willingness
to walk away from the negotiation table.
You say, “You know what?
There’s actually another Corvette dealer
down the street.
Maybe I’ll just go there.”
And the car dealer says, “Well, you know
what.
You see all these people standing in line
here.
They all want to buy this Corvette.”
You each threaten to walk.
But if you don’t walk you might end up typically
somewhere in the middle of those two other
numbers: 40, 80, you might end up around 60.
However, this probably isn’t the best agreement
that you could have come to.
All this is doing is arguing over one single
factor: a number.
And that’s the problem of positional bargaining,
is that I might have a lot of other interests
at stake but none of them are getting shared
within this very strict form of positional
bargaining.
There’s another form of negotiation that
at the Harvard Negotiation Project some of
my colleagues have developed, we call it “Interest
Based” negotiation.
The idea here is let’s not argue over positions,
let’s argue over underlying interests.
“Why do you want the car?”
“Well I want the car because I have three
kids, three boys.
I want a safe car.
I don’t really care about the sunroof.
I don’t need to look that cool, you know.
But I want a car that’s not that expensive.
I want one that’s energy efficient.
And these are all of my interests.”
Now the car dealer has his or her own interests.
If I ask you right now on camera what day
do you think I bought my most recent car—
Literally what day—you should know.
It was December 31 right at the end of the
year, because I knew one of the interests
of the car dealer in my area was they needed
to get these cars off the lot for the next
year’s cars.
They were more likely to go lower because
they had other interests at stake.
So interest based negotiation says don’t
just focus on the positions, what you say
you want; focus on the underlying interests.
And this is just as true in contemporary society.
Whether it’s a business example – two
people arguing over a contract.
Don’t just focus on the positions, focus
on the underlying interests.
When it comes to policy in the United States
or elsewhere you say “This is your position
on healthcare.
I say this is mine.”
Let’s not argue over the positions.
What are the underlying interests?
Why is that policy the one you want.
Then you can extract so much more value when
you focus on the level of underlying interests.